all their different colors are like
party favors today we're gonna guess the
price of period products that's a period
just gonna remain generally oblivious
like feminine products I get sent out a
lot to like buy pads and stuff only pads
though I'm at the pad guy I got style to
go colors you got sizes eight I had to
FaceTime my mom one time because there
were so many pads as far as like the
cost of it goes I don't really have the
slightest idea I think it's a tampon it
looks super high that it seems pretty
simple like simple technology wait does
that go inside of them oh you push it up
there you go
yep you gotta sit oh you two different
sizes they got a very throughout the
cycle you know because it rises and
falls like the mean 34 tampons will last
you like I can't do that math yeah it's
just like a bunch of cards or string
likes a cheap plastic probably about ten
bucks
nine dollars maybe like this that's
great I just think I'm a with that
packaging Diva Cup I like the name what
don't it's in her troop it in wash and
reinsert that sounds like a lot of work
how do you do this layer you put this in
a dishwasher
we're up to 12 hours at a time cuz it
gets full your cup runneth over this
seems more expensive though cuz like
that's like yeah the other one was just
like soft folded up paper and 2040 and I
drill this happy happy doing that $12.99
I want 15 I am I'm offended for women
that this is so expensive it's only one
no you use it forever the minstrel [ __ ]
can't follow ups the word soft cup with
a menstrual disk these things all sounds
so scared too but your nipple literally
goes remove hook your finger under the
rim
slowly pull and then just both so it
can't be felt while wearing
doesn't it can be worn during sex
how this is like you know my size well I
never mind I take that back
the Diva Cup is like an electric razor
that you're gonna use forever and this
one is like one of those disposable like
one time use you're going ten dollars I
am surprised that these are more
expensive than the tampons though
because it's like I feel like tampons
are more common and like probably better
simply summer's eve coconut water
cleansing cloth is this for when like
you don't use any of the aforementioned
products and just kind of have to like
clean up as it goes just remember front
to back not factor if you have like a
heavy float like this is not gonna help
you very much I imagine they help
maintain a healthy pH making sure it
doesn't get too basic down there's a
good smell for any part of the body
makes me think I'm at the beach Oh water
just one in my nose
I'm gonna in five dollars $4.99 it's my
happy coat for that thank God I don't
have to ever invest in these products
there's so many different like
confounding factors that can go into
this number you know like maybe some
women have more flow than others or like
some girls have like their period
earlier than others definitely adds
absolutely especially to like you know
lower-income women who probably can't
really be spending that much on that and
it has an elastic demand like you have
to buy exactly I think if the roles were
reversed and men had periods instead of
women I think that the world in general
would be a completely different place
think about like guys I'm gonna really
buy nothing's exclusively for ya
pralaya logical purpose likes me yeah
maybe to shave but you can't really
compare there's no bar that has that big
old bowl in the other door that's just
like here's some free pad I also think
like people would try and get on top of
it and like making it more affordable
yeah men would probably be a lot more
careless with it if I could just be like
blood
really have here yes it's just a random
erections but you don't really like to
pay for those this does it for free